reacciones no se hicieron esperar ante
la victoria de gabriel boric
varios líderes de latinoamericanos de
derecha e izquierda hicieron llegar sus
felicitaciones al mandatario electo
entre otras quién rotulaciones desde
argentina y colombia llegaron mensajes
de twitter de parte de los presidentes
alberto fernández e iván duque
respectivamente
quiero felicitar a gabriel boric por
haber sido elegido presidente del
querido pueblo de chile debemos asumir
el compromiso de fortalecer los lazos de
hermandad que unen a nuestros países y
de trabajar unidos a la región para
poner fin a la desigualdad en américa
latina' felicitamos a gabriel boris por
su elección como nuevo presidente de
chile expresamos nuestro interés en
seguir trabajando conjuntamente para
fortalecer la histórica y fraterna
relación bilateral que nos une somos
países hermanos también se sumaron las
felicitaciones de los presidentes de
bolivia luis arce de cuba miguel
díaz-canel bermúdez pedro castillo de
perú y nicolás maduro de venezuela
previamente los simpatizantes estallaron
en júbilo en las calles de santiago
muchos años de abuso y necesitamos una
renovación en la política y tengo muchas
esperanzas
en el lado empresario y la derecha
56% de los votos válidos en este
balotaje gabriel boric será el
presidente más joven en la historia de
chile